look at this wild map of every public
sauna in Finland this was made by a
Reddit user and I have no way of
factchecking it but one things for
certain is that fins love their sonas
every government building is required to
have one and not just to relax to
conduct diplomacy as well the Finnish
president and the head of the Soviet
Union sounded together and they came to
some good agreements that allowed
Finland to stay neutral in the Cold War
Two sweaty naked world leaders
negotiating finland's neutrality during
the Cold War in a sauna I freaking love
it Finland just joined NATO and guess
what NATO is installing a sauna and here
in Washington DC where I live The
Finnish Embassy has a sauna Society
where they invite people to come sauna
with them and talk about global Affairs
am I making this video because I
secretly want to be invited to the
Finnish SAA Society here in Washington
DC yes so Finland if you are hearing
this I accept your invite if you'll have
me if you want to better understand
global politics follow along for more